I
well we moved out here to LA to start
make us to do with my husband and the
whole group and it kind of started with
a conversation between Lisa and I we
were already in LA maker studios had
gotten started and Lisa Nova came was
just visiting at our house and she was
talking about what was going on and she
mentioned yeah we have the Spanish
vertical we have this and this going on
but we've really like to start a mom's
whole network I wonder who I could get
to help me with that you know I was kind
of like oh that would be cool I'm really
busy bah blah blah whatever and then um
so she kind of just planted that seed
and I kind of thought about it for a
couple weeks and then she came out to
visit and we started talking about it we
just thought we can really do this like
this could be a awesome thing and they
had already started she was thinking
about starting a channel and Carly had
already started hers but yeah and that's
that's how it kind of the the seat got
planted and we were just talking about
it and then like from there it was like
planning planning planning we had so
many I was like coming up with different
show I did it was like a snowball and I
rolling so quickly and getting bigger
and we were all just like I'm going to
give up and
we were moved we moved out here yeah
yeah so fast oh my gosh I remember I had
three jobs I had to quit right three
letters up I'm done like what do you
want to do I'm gonna make Internet
videos it's always so long i think it
was it was even that night that we
actually got in line and we booked the
we got the name of the moms do on
youtube we were like we kind of want it
to be life of you like a show like that
more like why don't we just do the moms
yeah
each episode is usually based on viewers
comments and what people are asking like
we it ranges from talk about serious
topics like bullying and depression and
self esteem to like our birth story
periods and ready it can be anything
yeah so I'm just trying to cover and off
yeah and I think one thing I really love
about our shows are really trying to
relate with our audience and what
they're wanting to hear from us trials
and experiences they're going through
and it's kind of funny it's almost
trending a little bit it seems like when
one person has a comment how many people
will thumbs up calm and like that and it
kind of opened your eyes to see what so
many people are going on going through
or going you know Trent trending in that
sound like back to school and people
being worried about their first days of
back to school and so it's good for us
to see those comments with a thumbs up
because we know what people want to hear
from us and I think those are the
comments we usually pick from I think
that's a great thing about YouTube as we
do get instant you know feedback we can
tell like right when we post a video we
know exactly what they think about it
and what they want to hear about next
and it's just it's amazing and something
really exciting that it's coming up is
we're going to be doing it live yeah so
we're going to be
to directly interact with our audience
which is so exciting I think a great
show is when we talked about our birth
stories and help me felt be coming
months for the first time because we
really got in touch with our audience
through that I feel like they knew we
were being real we were just telling it
how it was and they I feel like they
could relate to us I mean they could
just see that side of us so I really
love that oh yeah I liked I like Robert
any any choice are doing the moms do I
always just feel like that's what we
really are being I mean that's where we
have a chance to really show our
audience who we are and I'll to connect
with them with you know the things that
we've been through so I can't pick a
particular time but I deserves to feel
really blessed to be able to catch with
these women they're so smart and
uplifting and they have good advice so I
feel I feel like I it's really hard to
pick just one episode I mean I think I
guess one memorable one was when we
talked we had closed ow on we talked
about spanking I think and periods and
it was like one of those like what I'm
talking about I only get on this topic
but it was just hilarious i'll never
know
I think it's fun what do we get done
because I feel like every time I get
done with something it's like that
really needed if you talked about yeah
so every time we get done with an
episode of ink we can't wait for it to
you know be
just do it yeah don't do it don't let
fear hold you back I think come up with
something that you love to do because if
you genuinely love what you're doing
then you're going to start to be
successful at it and people are going to
see through you're passionate about what
you're doing there they're going to be
drawn in because if you're trying to you
know make a channel about oh well this
this is really successful I should try
doing this and you're not really
passionate about it then it's not going
to work it's going to fail so just be
passionate about what you're doing and
then be patient because it takes a lot
of time to just build it up and and
enjoy the journey I mean you too is a
great place to meet people make friends
and just express yourself however you
want to I like wish I said about I think
from a number like day one we've all
just you know really big who you are and
you know sell that and be proud of that
and ignore the haters and just you know
really hold on to the positive and move
forward with that and I think it will
helps your channel kind of guide you in
a way you know there's like you'll put
videos out when you learn kind of what
you know what your audience resonates
you know more with and what does better
in it so it's like kind of focus on that
but don't let anything that like if you
have a bad video don't let that stop you
like plus I just keep going look for
with the positive and
why don't I just do it put it out there
okay well not to to our own horn but I
think we take pride in that we are the
number one moms network on youtube and
that's pretty exciting to be able to
claim that title yeah we have over 200
million views across the network and
it's just growing and we're super proud
of it if you want to see it in ww
youtube com / the moms view come join us
we'll have something to say whether your
mom or not yeah but one thing you are
you yeah everyone is welcome yeah thank
you so much for watching yes if you guys
want to check out the whole interview go
to new media rockstars calm and you can
catch the whole crazy moms gone loose
interview it's a three year but I love
it going out by the way okay I know I
the science guy here CEO monitors and I
welcome to New meeting rock stars if I
understand as I mean feature